good evening everybody this is a meeting
of the planning and development
management Committee of Trafford Council
my name is councilor Ben Hartley I'm the
chair of the committee on my immediate
right it's councilor Barry Winn Stanley
who's the vice chair of the committee
um on our left and right are offices
from the council's planning team
highways team and legal team and then
further on further around on the tables
at the side are members of the committee
who are all uh local councilors and I'll
introduce them by name uh when they wish
to speak the meeting is being recorded
by by video and audio so it's live
streamed on the council's YouTube
channel and the recording is available
to view for um a period afterwards as
well
we'll start the agenda with attendances
and apologies for absence so all the
members of the committee are present
apart from uh councilor Thomas who had
to give his apologies a short notice for
unavoidable reasons so there is no
member I think as a substitute for him
this evening so that's the only apology
and the only person absent yet okay item
number two is Declarations of Interest
so this is for members to give notice of
any personal or prejudicial interest and
the nature of that interest relating to
any item on the agenda in accordance
with the adopted code of conduct are any
members looking to make a declaration of
interest on any item this evening
no okay thank you we'll move on to item
three the minutes of the last meeting so
it's to receive and if so agreed to
approve the correct record the minute so
the last meeting held on the 8th of
December 2022
um
cancer when Stanley's happy to move that
uh and cancel the proxy or you have to
second that so we'll accept those
minutes as a an accurate record of the
last meeting thank you for that item
number four is questions from members of
the public so this item is uh a maximum
of 15 minutes
um to be allocated to public questions
submitted by 4 pm on the Working Day
prior to the meeting questions must be
within the remit of the committee all
relevant to items appearing on the
agenda we haven't received any questions
for this meeting
um so we'll move on now to item number
five which is the additional information
report
um
the copies are available at the back of
the room and I know that it's quite a
lengthy report so I hope that members of
all a chance to to read through that and
we will consider the information in that
report as we go through each of the
applications
which takes us on to item six which is
applications for permission to develop
we have three applications this evening
and for the benefit of people
um either watching online or in the room
for each of these items we will first of
all have a presentation from a member of
the planning team to introduce the item
we may then have speakers both for and
against the applications we'll hear from
the speakers against first and then the
speakers four and members of the
committee will then debate the item and
I'll introduce them if they wish to
speak
um just for clarity once we've heard
from our speakers for and against an
item the discussion is then over to the
committee so we cannot uh usually engage
in any debate with the speakers so it's
then just over to us to discuss the item
um so uh with that we'll look at the
first application the first one we're
going to consider is application 107 877
which is the Bowdoin Hotel
and we will have an introduction on this
from Mr Pearson thank you
thank you chairman this application
seeks full planning permission for a
comprehensive Redevelopment of the
former Bowden Hotel Site which is
located on the east side of Langham Road
in Bowen
the site's located within the Bowden
Conservation Area and adjacent to the
hail station Conservation Area
the Bowdoin hotel is identified as a
positive contributor in the Bowden
Conservation Area appraisal
the proposed development comprises the
conversion and extension of the hydro
building to provide a 95 Place
Children's Day Nursery
conversion of two semi-detached Villas
to provide six Apartments direction of a
51 bedroom Care Home an erection of six
townhouses in two blocks
all other existing buildings on the site
are proposed to be demolished access to
the various parts of the development is
proposed from both Langham Road and
Marlborough Road and we've got a number
of slides here now which
um which kind of show you what the
scheme's about so
um you can see now
I'll just talk you through that
um
the care home is here on the marble Road
uh part of the site
um up here is the day Nursery with the
retained Hydro building there if you can
see my cursor and an extension
is it not do apologize top left then is
that existing Hydro building and the
extension to it to the left the left
hand Mouse building on that Langham Road
Frontage in the center of the site
um opposite the car park entrance from
Marlborough Road is other retained
Villas
um
the green area to the left of that is is
a garden area